hey man how are you good good we're
talking about Brett Kavanaugh of a
Supreme Court nominee yeah yeah but for
Michael have an idea to act like that's
a shocking thing for someone to say in
high school or college is just [ __ ]
stupid right especially a virgin like
that sounds like something a virgin
would say right yeah find them French
them [ __ ] them and forget them finger
that's off it's also stupid the ability
now we're just going back and grabbing
things people held a guy are you I'm 28
okay so people going back and grabbing
[ __ ] people say when they're 17 and 16
and acting like that identifies them as
adults it's just it's very sense it's a
guy I've said something that I've had
two awful opinions in the past I
probably got some awful opinions now
that I'm not aware of he'll give me 10
years to be like oh god I can't believe
I thought that right right you'll be
like 33 and you'll be like I don't know
I said a lot of douchey things that
wasn't I don't agree with any of the
stuff that that guy said it seems that
we don't seem to allow or believe in
growth in any way like that's especially
the commune's people go through your old
tote wasting like yeah I said some
stupid [ __ ] yeah cuz I used to be a
stupid [ __ ] it comes with the job you're
talking for a living at times
dumb [ __ ] flies out of your mouth yeah
for some reason were held accountable
but you said this like oh did I did I
say something in the form of a joke and
a stand up say so you've decided to take
seriously also fail to see how that's my
problem but sure
yeah they act like you're carving it in
granite in writing this is how I feel
and I'm sort of like you like it like
it'll be one tweet from years ago right
and there's no tweet since then that
relate to that and so you're like that's
the person I'm not that guy anymore like
I wouldn't do that anymore
well how do we know because there's been
six years of tweets where you don't have
any tweets that are like that one yeah
also you went so far out of your way to
find that tweet yeah
you literally went through all of my you
know private messages or the ones just
other people to find the one time I said
something a little bit [ __ ] up like
you Ron to get offended that I don't see
how I have to it seems like it seems
like you're a little bit more damaged
than me yeah if you're searching like
that the damage seems to be on you and
they're fine and stuff for people like
football players they're going back and
grabbing tweets from high school oh my
god give us a [ __ ] with you if I had to
it obviously I'm too old for Twitter in
high school but I would have humiliated
myself I mean it would do it and
terrible to have Twitter one occasion
occasionally when Facebook throws up
something from ten year
ago for me just like a state as I posted
I'm like Jesus I used to be the dumbest
person on the [ __ ] planet
yeah we still am but it's nice to know
that I'm still grown but you grew up
with that like when you were when I
guess Twitter was uh when you were
probably a teenager when Twitter popped
up right I'd only heard go ahead and
tell us about 19 yeah
how about Facebook do you always
remember that being there and hold his
Facebook Facebook was like mm well
Facebook started like when I was in
college in like 2003 ish policy routine
there's room that's when it started but
it was exclusive to colleges then it
didn't start like for high school kids
until like 2006 yeah I think I uh I
think I joined all the internet so I
stuff in about 2019 because ya know to
30 2009 cuz before that I was still just
enjoying the porn Yankees porn yeah it
was like oh you know you can catch with
your friends on this thing I was like
that's not why I bought this exactly I
can see them in person I can't watch a
girl piss in person right right yeah you
know there's like tons of free porn on
this too I just
guys they updated every day way more sex
than I am this feel good see at least
you hit Wi-Fi when I was I and we first
got a computer I was like there was it
was all [ __ ] uh you know 14k yeah so
was dial-up it was awful I downloaded
you know if you just watch a photo oh
yeah download but it was so amazing to
have this coming into your house I'll
never that I mean with what a revolution
to be able to watch porn on a screen if
you sitting there in like half of the
photo would be downloaded and then your
mom would pick up the phone which would
interrupt the connection because it was
all done through phone lines oh and
you'd be signed off what the [ __ ] yeah I
was right about to see that that have
been a great improv the Nixon speech
five years ago well you you started
doing stand-up young right 17 years and
even that's a great when did you start
21 but I mean 17 is a big different in
17 and 21 yeah and where was your first
set the stand comedy club and M ed Umrah
it's like a decent real well I say that
I actually did geek when I was 16 but if
you have asked any of the seven people
in that audience why I did was not
[ __ ] comedy oh it's terrible yeah
yeah yeah I so I cut my first gig is the
one in like a real [ __ ] comedy club
The Beginner's nebulas still
who your influence is growing up with
like Billy Connolly and those guys or is
he like two old Conley was yeah I
obviously being Scottish grew up
watching a lot him thanks to my
grandparents I was like my dad made me
watch Bill Hicks when I was six years
old so I grew up watching that I love
Dennis Lillee
a lot British comics like Ed Byrne and
filter person mark Lamarr
I just watched everything right before
the internet came out used to just go in
eBay and just buy any VHS a--'s of any
column of comedy yeah yes our friends
are not DVDs find some weird ones as
well if you've ever seen Jamie Foxx's
into the fox hole special have I ever
seen his stand-up I'm not sure I know I
remember from in living color I don't
know if I ever saw him actually do stand
out it's real interesting is it bad yeah
but there's just one bit where he's just
got this catchphrase and it's not a
catchphrase but he just keeps repeating
it over and over and over again until
the audience starts singing along with
it just does a punchline and then
pretends to smoke a joint and just goes
you better blow that [ __ ] out and he
first time he says that there's no
reaction but then by like the fourth
time the audience like all will join in
that's what you do it's really
uncomfortable oh yeah there's some
decent jokes in there yeah but it's yeah
I haven't seen comedy like that at the
time so a young person do you sit there
going like I need a catchphrase I'm
gonna be an idiot I get jokes are okay
but I need a catchphrase watching a
catchphrase get shoehorned in a good
catchphrase it just works and a bad one
is the worst thing in comedy
catchphrases they should be for star yes
you say something people cook you know
you say they're sorry you know you say
this a lot and you're like oh I guess
yeah I do that's now something that's
that will be my thing he opposed to that
took me being like I'm just gonna say
I've got a giant dick seven times in a
five minute set so it's my thing it's
what I say
cuz I've got a watching somebody bomb is
so much because I was reading a little
bio about you and you're saying that you
don't mind bomb because part of what we
do yeah and you were scared to do it in
front of
even when a bomb would Chappelle when
you worked with him yeah which is
understandable but on the Jamie Foxx
roast years that Jamie Foxx versus a
comedian bombing on that roast
oh I don't think so oh it's a great love
it it's watching people mom is just so
fantastic yeah I always think it's
funnier if it's your friend
I don't think actually it's it's
basically if it's a comic that you know
you've grown up with and you know
they're great and then just watching
them bomb you're just like it's and they
can see you just smiling and the worst
laugh on stage to receive is the one
from three comics in the back when they
say you do your favorite [ __ ] joke
and it just dies in front of everyone
use here three covers good because you
know they're not enjoying your act like
I'll bomb it sometimes that I would hear
from outside like if the Comedy Cellar
when you walk in there's like a little
space outside to stand and sometimes you
won't see who's out there but I've been
bombing I just hear ah and it's Keith
and I know [ __ ] laughs why Keith is
abrasive isn't he he's a [ __ ] he's a
cancer a cancer of a person he's a
cancer on society oh yeah good good way
better
yeah actually more believable than star
science that's right yeah yeah it
actually means something yeah so you
started at 17 and how long did it take
you to get going because I can't from 17
to 21 I can't imagine being dedicated to
anything at that age that was great you
are you were dedicated to Satan I was
yeah I was very a little devil worshiper
but I wasn't evil when Jim was in and
high-schoolers shoots out the enemy
ships we're doing doing Jim was in high
school he signed a contract in blood
selling his soul to Satan all filled up
on souls right now I just won this
morning old juicy but come back tomorrow
we may have a place where you keep this
one for now no I know I thought Satan
might need a suburban dick sucker wasn't
for anything it was just in case I just
thought it would be cool and then I felt
that he might as well but right yeah and
then he did the really cool thing
because he's obviously living at home of
course I was and he taped the contract
to his parents bedroom door no no it's
been my door alright I would never
apparently kind of fruity to do that to
your own your action rebellion is you'll
sell your soul to the devil but I'm not
gonna graffiti mom and dad think you
were committed to satanic work well he
hadn't responded so I didn't know if he
accepted he accepted eyestrain responded
[Laughter]
I I have a picture there's my friend
Devon for blood here was it so is it you
pricked your finger or was it like a
quill and I was a probably a box cutter
but I was that I'd written out some
corny lyrics and my friend was laughing
at me like you [ __ ] right I found
that I found I keep everything I save
everything so I found I have all these
old family pictures and things from
growing up because it was I didn't I
mean ima envious of people had video of
themselves as kids there's no video of
me right at least if there is this
probably doesn't damage yeah there's
videos I'm sure they're in evidence room
so yes so I I have a lot of photos you
have video when you work in right yes my
parents a young Jim that he's young yeah
interesting videos I'm not like right it
was not an entertaining child I just
best shot myself on camera my parents
like well these are wonderful memories
it's so nice to have though when you
were 17 we do you feel like you were
more because you're doing comedy right
between 17 and 21 a lot of us are not
very self-aware and doing a lot of
douchey things you know do you feel like
because you were doing stand-up then you
started becoming a little bit more
self-aware and self-critical earlier
yeah definitely like I think I don't
know I'm still an absolute deckhand I've
absolutely [ __ ] up over the years but
I do think like just being hyper aware
of it and about I had nothing else to
say when I was 17 like I didn't have any
valuable or valid opinions on anything
so it was just oh my mum's [ __ ] weird
now yeah we hear and but yeah getting
into comedy really helped me I think
improve as a person my parents will
disagree but I think I improved if they
want you to do this or something else no
they were genuinely thrilled with my
dad's you know huge comedy fans I mean
they made me when I was in high school
they're like still try and get into
University and then I did get into
university and my mom was the one that
was like well it's going well so don't
go yeah just stay here for an extra two
years and cuz I don't know how you guys
are set up
over there but here you just [ __ ] owe
a lot of money when you're finished with
college you uh yeah it's like sometimes
you get a job sometimes you don't so if
you can make money doing you know gigs
if I can take the money oh man they
might have like what my friends went to
university I was kind of jealous because
they were gonna meet all these new
people make new friends get [ __ ] late
to have their own independence I mean
while I'm living at home with my parents
still for an extra two years and then
after four years I was a marginally
successful comic and they all had debt
and I was like because you get out of
college you haven't it's not like you
get credit for that experience no not at
all like now you start life you're like
yeah I started life four years ago
because guess what they're doing after
college moving making with their parents
yeah yeah yeah I got a psychology degree
did you know what are you gonna do with
that right what the [ __ ] will you do it
I mean if you know I thought it was
really interesting when I was taking the
classes oh interesting cool man enjoy
that yeah yeah yeah maybe one day when
I'm more successful you can be my
therapist what did you want to do is
this is stand-up like the thing you're
like yeah well I want to do stand-up or
did you just kind of say I'll try it and
see no I don't want it I want to be a
stand-up somebody like I grew up with I
loved it and it's still my focus now
which people you know agents in LA can't
understand they want you to act yeah
yeah I don't I acting but they're like
what's your focus I'm like exactly what
I'm doing right now like I just a bigger
version of this do they want the work
that's a [ __ ] worse you're at LA they
want you to have like a seven-minute
thing that defines you that they can
write a show they're so stupid and
uncreated they think that you should
bring it to them the guy you're you're
you're you're an uber driver
your mother's sick you okay I'll write a
five minute act on that and then they
can develop a show around it you're like
it doesn't work just tell the agent it's
like you're my agent just come see my
stand-up yeah and get a taste of Who I
am like it's out there it's public
people know so I always like when agents
good this is what your fans want you go
I think I think I know what my fans
would yeah I mean that's how I [ __ ]
got them in the first place right yeah
yeah yeah but when you have a certain
amount of success and they think this is
what you have to do to get more and it's
like no you just keep doing this and if
it works it works right no yeah because
all of these idiots the like man they're
gonna tell their idiot friends who will
also like me and that'll naturally grow
as opposed to making my comedy wider
spread more accessible but you clearly
got a publicist because at some point
you know this Netflix for the Netflix
specials come out in America which I
guess is like Netflix is trying to take
a lot of European comics that might not
have as much exposure in the
and kind of push them out right so you
get which is like it's amazing what
Netflix is doing I don't know how they
make their choices because some people
are getting 15 minutes mmm some people
are getting a half an hour you got two
hours yeah which is amazing
did you wind up when did you shoot these
one it's called dark and one is called
jigsaw yeah filmed dark earlier this
year at the Belasco theater in LA and
that was after we got the Netflix deal
but jigsaw I just I'd come off my tour
in Australia so that was when it was
like the show was at its best I've been
doing it every day but we didn't have
the Netflix deals my agent just made the
very wise call of gee I'll put me I put
the money forward and we just filmed it
to Netflix specifications and then just
hoped and prayed that yeah yeah yeah and
we went what we've got another one
sitting here for you and they went yeah
sure I mean if you filmed it oh so
you're just sitting on that one yeah
yeah yeah yeah we noticed before
anything of the deal had come in and
then they were like we want to because
they look very similar that you spent
like in the sense that it feels like
they were shot at almost as a package
know through said one was filmed in
Australia and one was filmed that's
amazing
yeah it's smart to do though a lot of
people are doing that now where you film
something you just make sure again it's
to their specifications and you know
whatever they want it shot in and
hopefully they'll buy it cuz they a lot
of times it's cheaper for them to buy a
special than it is for them to [ __ ]
finance one right now yeah and then much
there you know the one I filmed in
Australia I just got my main is a very
good DOP to film it and I was just hired
you know because they want you to what
we're certain people where's this when I
got to work with all the people I loved
I mean and then when I did in LA they
sign me up with great people as well but
it's just much easier that way yeah
absolutely
but the reason I said you clearly got
published this is because now like as
the Netflix thing rolls out every time
you like you know pick up the newspaper
whatever it's like did you know he broke
up 4000 couples and you're like what but
that's the that's the you you've now got
a mythology that follows you around yeah
yeah I'm very much enjoying the breakups
and the divorces that are coming in I
have obviously a lot of people are sort
of saying oh you know some of these are
you know probably lies and I was like
yeah yeah we've also got to take it to
cut the amount of people that have
broken up that haven't told me about it
because they don't want me to get the
credit because I'm enjoying it so much
right now what is it about the special
that's causing a breakup is it all just
about relationships yeah the last 20
minutes a jigsaw is basically it wasn't
meant to be a breakup show it
in a very sort of wonky wave it was my
answer to being like it's a love layer
to single people I enjoy being single I
think there's absolutely nothing wrong
with it I think society forces us to get
into relationships because [ __ ]
people are terrified of being alone so I
just heard that in 20 minute routine
turns out resonates with 5000 people how
long you been single I've been single
for three years yeah it's easier to be
single though when you're like
good-looking dude with a Scottish accent
in your 20s right yeah but that's
goatish accent counts for [ __ ] all in
scotland yeah I guess so I was thinking
when you're here it's like plus there's
like you know with the population
there's a hundred and fifty women their
total and some of them are you know just
women right yeah it is being single but
as you get older it gets depressing does
it yeah a little bit not it's not that
I'm craving a person but once in a while
the things you miss are not even sex cuz
that's the easy stuff it's just like
yeah let me see somebody to do this with
companionship if you're doing something
yeah I got a dog it's not the same
because then you can't [ __ ] it society
Frank yeah it's PC gone mad thanks a lot
Obama yeah yeah you think you've do you
think companionship as you get older
with what you start looking for more
yeah but being single is nice too
because you can kind of do what you want
to do you know but once in a while you
look for a little bit more like yeah
just something to do with someone yeah
but I was the thing that I you can get
companionship from you know other people
in your life I got all my close friends
you know some of them are girls as well
he's going right I've not spooning some
in a while can weeks but [ __ ] it but
then again I'm young so maybe that's an
entire difference it is yeah and do they
have a boyfriend who knows they're
spooning because no girl wants no guy
wants his girlfriend spooning no there's
just spooning it we're just buddies this
profession always just in the small
that's actual
it was it was it was there was underwear
on but we were both wearing the same
underwear yeah there are people that
cuddle this guy I think his name is Adam
and there's a site called like to cuddle
list and there's people that actually
need affection so bad they hire Cutler's
they don't [ __ ] you they literally will
just come over and hug do something
sexual oh my god I think it's a sensual
thing but a sensual probably for the
person hiring you right I think that the
cuddler probably just comes over here
there's all kinds of rules all right I
haven't done it yeah you can't resort
about it you know no I on some level you
want a cuddler no you want to cuddle a
little bit I don't know it's hard for me
to cuddle without being turned on I have
to have something with a person to hug
them right thank you just hug a stranger
I thought was attracted to her I could
that's a weird thing yet cuddling with a
that would be awful if you were the
professional hugger and you turned up to
someone's door and you're like now I
can't do you yes I can't share a human
moment with you I apologize here is all
of your money but you are [ __ ]
disgusting and if you're a professional
cuddler you always have to carry a pizza
with you just so you can pretend you're
the wrong door did you order them I
cannot are the PETA center health and
safety yeah and if you're ugly - I mean
germs get on there yeah that's gotta
suck if you show up but it's a big
business I guess people love it yeah
people like to hug and cuddle is it a
big business though I've been hearing
about it for a while really yeah I don't
think it's that big of a business who
the [ __ ] would want to hire a cuddler
Troy you ever hire a professional Cutler
no but I get it what I mean there are
people that like worship feed their way
into that I mean everybody has their
something this is supposed to be
non-sexual is supposed to be just
companionship well I mean the people
that worship feet don't want sex either
yeah but in society is very sexual I
mean you're gonna tell me that I don't
know if one of these attractive girls
some guys going in to hug her and cuddle
you don't they're not all really think
she's very beautiful but they're not all
attractive so you think they're jerking
off when they after they leave like the
clients are treating I don't know I
don't know
jerking off in the bathroom when they're
done in the toilet
so I don't know I think so there's no
doubt in my mind I knew why would you
want because it's not real companionship
if it's from a stranger just hugging
it's the physical yeah it's intimacy
yeah the closeness I guess I mean I
still find it [ __ ] really hard yeah
yeah strange just a hug a person yeah
just [ __ ] ubereats with intimacy
because even though obviously surely
like getting a hug is obviously nice it
makes you feel better
surely the second after the hug they're
like that's my shift over and they [ __ ]
off you're like oh no I am incredibly
lonely if anything the fact I had to pay
someone to drive to my house to hug me
it's just really round home might make
you yeah yeah when they leave you're
like oh yeah that for them this was just
80 bucks
I believe I just paid somebody to hug me
yeah yeah for 20 40 bucks more I could
have paid someone to [ __ ] I would have
felt really good to do although if
you're hugging someone for money and
then they're you're done you might be
done hugging in 30 minutes and go huh
all right I got that out of my system
now I've been hugged I'm finished
there's no other responsibilities the
level of crazy that you are if you're
paying somebody to hug you it's not out
of your system hmm I don't know about
that maybe I'll try it please try it
please
by the way you also would not be this
like no I'm gonna prove Sam wrong see
normal people hug - I did it yeah you're
not normal Jim there's nothing normal
about you but I it is a big business
that's the point did you uh do you find
that since you did this special that
women I would imagine because I was
watching this special and I was like he
is probably getting more women than ever
because women will watch it and either
they'll be like [ __ ] that guy but kind
of have that oh he's a jerk thing or
dude the thing that I've seen women do
over and over again which is like oh he
doesn't want a relationship cuz he
hasn't met the right girl that is a load
of it yeah yeah yeah there's that figure
of like it's because he's not made me
yet ago no no it's because I'm very
comfortable with myself and you know I
travel for nine months of the year and I
enjoy being selfish at this time in my
life
right there like not abut me though what
happened to the last one how long we
were at the last one I was with her for
it was one about three
but it was quite intense brutal was it
oh yeah who broke up with her I broke up
with her was it was it did she was she
like was she stuck to you or was she
okay with you leaving no no she was not
okay with no it was a big ol thing but
that was the one where I just went I
basically did the same thing every every
two years I'll get into a three-month
relationship I'm like it's been two
years maybe I'm ready for one and then I
get into it in three months and I'm like
oh this is [ __ ] awful and I hate this
right yeah it's not that it's me I'm
just like then come some points wouldn't
it like how was your day and then I'll
tell them about my day and then they'll
start telling me about theirs and just
part my head goes I didn't [ __ ] ask
and the second you realize you're not
interested right now you're like all I
need to leave you like you gently
deserve someone who gives a [ __ ] about
your boring day and writes not me right
so now do you do you sit there and go
like look I need you to understand I am
an [ __ ] mm-hmm I'm doing this because
I'm a jerk I'm being selfish it's over
and then they're like you're [ __ ]
jerk and you're like right yeah
establish like are you a pretty honest
guy when it comes to breaking up and
just taking the heat yeah absolutely
yeah just good and there's nothing you
could there's nothing you could have
done to make this work right all me it's
all of my stuff there's nothing you
could have done I'm just I'm not
interested the last girlfriend did not
take your word for it she did not take
my word that was a phone stalking where
she's showing up at gigs no that wasn't
so bad no no no like it was just there
was a it was a heated argument and then
I had to just her sever all ties and
we're decent times now but there was a
long period when it was I think we both
hate did you live with it I've never
lived with anyone I've never lived I've
never lived with a partner now I've
lived with friends yeah yeah I had a
roommate and his girlfriend but I kind
of I wouldn't mind it at this point I've
just never done it and to me I'm too old
to adjust I'm afraid of that - I'm 50 I
like my own [ __ ] everywhere yeah I think
if somebody comes in who's a just a
different level of cleanliness who you
are like I'm quite a clean person but if
you come in and like why is your Salix
there because that's what I leave my
socks let's just we have the longer
you're single as an adult the more
you're just like I figured out how life
is this is how I live my life and if you
can if we get along really well and I'm
attracted to you and you can enter in
to this life No then cool but if we
start changing things up I didn't you
know I already kind of had figured it
out already
yeah and the longer you go I feel like
the more stuck you are into this like
now I've already figured out how I do
things well I always think like if
you're getting into a relationship with
me my life is pretty good and you've got
to make it better right yeah yeah yeah
yeah and that can change it probably
will try but for the time being my life
skirts and if I'm gonna be in a
relationship you have it has to be
better than being single like you can't
be in a relationship with me and make it
worse than being single because being
single is always an option for me
right it's right there yeah the second
it's the second I'm annoyed or pissed
off and I am I'm like oh I'm just gonna
go back to the good version of this
right are you afraid of being alone you
know I've been doing that for a long
time yeah what I'm alone it's great
because you're not there being alone is
you're not here and I don't have to
answer this phone call every [ __ ] day
I see a cheater I have cheated but no
not on my not my last to achieve when I
was like 19 did you get caught no of
course not I probably did now right but
I kind of imagine she listened I cheated
and I felt really bad about it and I had
that thing in my head was like I change
out this there's no point telling her
because I'm you know beat myself up for
like ages and it made me realize that I
did like her so we stay together for
like another year and a half and I
didn't cheat a lot of times when you do
towel you're not telling to do the right
thing you're telling for your own yeah
to release your behind yeah but that's
[ __ ] up because totally [ __ ] it [ __ ]
the other person up and they never they
never trust you I know it's not only the
fact that they you know they don't trust
you they don't trust any partner after
that so I drank one oh I made a mistake
there's nothing she could I was drunk I
was an idiot I changed I felt bad about
it for ages
yeah living your [ __ ] yeah and get over
it and then we broke up fatty amicably
and I've you know never told her cuz she
just she doesn't need to know right oh
there's a path of Human Wreckage behind
me you are not all of your breakups
healthy good know how many of you added
I I know I mean a decent amount in 50
years you I mean cyber dating since I
was I guess 16 or whatever 17 little
girlfriend you know and I've just you
know the cheating you should put
yourself at 67 years old by the way
that you said over fifty years and then
you said I've been dating - yeah you
just you just age yourself at 67 Jim is
not 67 miss subtractive right right
they're changing his wiki right now a 67
year old comedian Jim Norton well
there's that actor Jim Norton we talked
about yesterday how old he is he looks
to be aware somewhere around 77 I think
he's like 73 yeah yeah I've cheated
before after a while you get so
comfortable with it you just become
comfortable lying so have you done have
you been in in situations now were you
like you've got somebody that you're
hooking up with or somebody that you're
a partner but not you're not in a
relationship right it's just like
somebody you're hanging out with right
now they think that this is building
towards a relationship you are well
aware that this is not building towards
a relationship mm-hmm and you have to
hit that and pass I always make sure
that I just all the way through it just
if I find that like if you're honest all
the way through you can't get in trouble
you can still look they can still be
annoyed but you can't be accused of
being a [ __ ] liar at any point but
you have you seen it like even when
you're honest they are like oh I didn't
like they're not hearing it yeah yeah
yeah I've had that and and you know you
just get into the uncomfortable
discussions but the and you can tell you
know through the way that I've actually
I'm just like just remind you I my thing
is always that I travel for like nine
months a year this job and I really like
that and I want to keep doing that
because you know that's how I'm gonna
become a better comic and you know I'm
not bringing anyone on the road with me
apart from my tour support right I'm
gonna I enjoy being single I'm gonna and
then also like if they ever don't get
the message you know bring them along to
a stand-up show what I talk about how
much I like being single you can see the
Menominee's feel like he doesn't mean
and I'm like no no no I'll do this bit
just to you oh my god I got I got a
girlfriend got really mad at me once I
was on stage you know you flirt with
someone in the crowd it's [ __ ] but
you're not just joking and asking them
out obnoxiously and you don't mean it
but she got really angry at me and I'm
like how could you not tell that was
[ __ ] I'm on stage there I mean
anything yeah that would be one of the
moments where you just call unless you
learn this lesson immediately that most
the things I say are jokes and I don't
mean them we've got to end this now
because I'm not getting into an argument
where I have to get into arguments on
the end
and what I explained something was just
a joke the last thing I want to home is
explaining that something was just yeah
I can joke yeah you know what I mean
that's the great because I'm married and
my wife never know whether it's about
her or about anybody else I don't
remember the last time she brought up
anything that I said on the air that
morning she doesn't listen
she just yeah half the time she isn't
the show
used to be better I mean the old morning
show yeah half the time she doesn't
listen and the other half she's just
like no I mean I don't know you're doing
this show like this that's just what you
do it's like a heightened version of
yourself
I understand it's true to you but it's
not fully you right exactly like I can
talk to you right now yeah and get the
answers yeah this is an actual
conversation really where did you open
for Chappelle the punch line in San
Francisco oh yeah that's how that's like
150 160 seat room with it's an amazing
Club and I he'll just go in there to
work to work out he'll do a string of
nights I mean I used to work out there
yet it's an amazing club you can't make
money there because it's so small so
you'll do cobs to make money because
it's a bigger place but like again if
Chappelle is not doing those gigs for
money he's doing them just to work on
myself yeah yeah I was I was amazing to
watch like it was just one of those yeah
I never wasn't even a dream come true
because I'd never even pictured it as a
potential thing right right yeah I had
no point am i setting in Scotland being
like one day all open for Dave Chappelle
sounds like a reasonable thing to dream
all right he's stars but I just saw a
trailer last night with David oh he's in
the star is born is he in that movie
nice isn't it
Lady gaga Bradley Cooper yeah yeah your
big Lady Gaga fan right I do I like her
a lot you do you know like it more as a
singer your would you consider yourself
a little monster yes I would yeah what I
liked her very much a few matters
um briefly for a photo but I don't know
her
I'm go talk to her would you like to a
lot would you make her your girlfriend
yeah she's sexy she's [ __ ] she looks
like she doesn't worth deodorant like
she she's [ __ ] sexy man she's like God
wasn't gritty but then sometimes I feel
like you're you're you're putting your
own fetishes out on I am yeah she looks
like the type who would be okay with
that yeah she's also just confident is
she
that's a big turn-on for me yeah any
girl that just confidently stands in
front of you in college a piece of chef
like oh yeah who is it about is it a
true story or no no I don't think it's a
true story I think it's like an old
movie or is it yeah they've remade the
film like seven or eight times yeah I
think Barbara Streisand was in one of
them yeah but they've changed this one
upper pairs they always do
oh yeah who else was it I always [ __ ]
this up with star 80 which was about
Dorothy stratten the Playboy model who
was murdered by her boyfriend which was
played by Eric Roberts in the movie
nobody knows any movie called star 80
bro star a Dorothy stratten the [ __ ] are
you talking about I mean come on Troy
you ever heard of a movie called stars
Kristofferson that's right Travis Rice
in star 80 you like that movie I think
that's fake I've never look up Dorothy
stratten look up starring Johnny Carson
interviewed her once it was very
interesting because it was not a great
interview but the fact that he was able
just robbed star 80 come on you guys is
that star 80 or 1983 it wasn't even a
big movie in thank you yes sir what
story of course it was the Dorothy
stratten story you know Dorothy stratten
is based on the true story of Playmate
of the Year Dorothy stratten her maid of
the year in 1981
oh my god but she was murdered by a
boyfriend that where many playmates have
been murdered over the years in 1980 she
was murdered who cares what's the big
story it's not a big story it was my own
idea Edie but that was what he was very
jealous it wasn't nominated for the
Golden Bear al Hemingway Eric Roberts
star he was in that movie for pete's
sake I hate to do this isn't it great in
that that it that is the great thing
about like this type of work is that you
can do something like the film star 80
where he's like you get a Golden Globe
nomination and for your craft it's like
oh my god I made this big movie I'm
getting nominations for awards and
fast-forward 35 years later and a bunch
of people will be in a room laughing at
what you made going nobody's ever heard
of that [ __ ] that's right well Jim's
also said it's so much neither it's his
accidental catchphrase like we've gone
back to the stuff yeah you know a movie
I like story
yeah Dorothy stratten I'm fascinated
with some of these old and I told you
the first time I met gene Simmons I
asked about a Playboy model who had been
in his shoots in the 70s star Stowe so I
what happened I said whatever happened
to star Stowe and he goes uh and then
Opie and Anthony laughed because they
thought I was making the name up uh-huh
they didn't know who she was
right know that it was a real person and
they laughed and she went that's not
funny she died yeah she was so [ __ ]
hot man she did genius to date her and
she would do pictures like the look of
the gene Simmons stars no pictures she's
dead she passed away I'm sorry sexy man
I'm sorry to hear that